in 2019 my life went from writing
30-minute long documentaries about
people who can aim pretty well in
videogames to now watching people eat
cat food on Twitch here on don't at me
we tried to cover it all from the most
serious stories to the craziest live
stream fuck-ups so today let's take a
look at some of the stuff that maybe
didn't make the cut and look back on a
year filled with crazy live stream
stories as far as I'm concerned there's
maybe no bigger theme on Twitch this
year than Bambi's whether it was people
getting the book thrown at them or
somehow managing to avoid bannings no
matter what they did most notably maybe
it was of course doctor disrespect who
took his persona maybe one step too far
at twitchcon straight into a bathroom
doc was live-streaming in his classic
persona at twitchcon
and how does cameraman follow him right
into a bathroom which is of course very
illegal and then of course we've got the
other side of the court a linen who
somehow threw her cat fed her cat
alcohol and then did whatever the hell
this is and managed to completely avoid
being banned which became the talk of
the platform yeah because you got
nothing you got nothing it caught you
know got the bookkeeper you've got
nothing when something has homegrown as
twitches at its core gets this popular
there's bound to be some policing issues
I mean it literally allows you to
livestream your life what do you think
is gonna happen everyone's gonna be nice
and respectful so I think a lot of what
happened on Twitch this year was people
kind of feeling it out seeing just how
far you could go without getting the
banhammer thrown down on you and as
we've covered extensively on this show
much of the conversation around the
platform has devolved into exactly what
you have to do or not do to get bad with
that in mind what's maybe even weirder
is while people argue about bannings in
the comments section for hours it's
actually come to inform a lot of what
we've started to see on Twitch itself
take someone like Miss Kim who grew
massively this year as an IRL stream
this is a guy who's truly taken the
insanity of live-streaming and minute
his entire brand in a lot of ways he's
become famous for being part of and
documenting what's going on in live
streaming on stream this is a guy that
made $5,000 staring at a wall start the
timer I am now staring at a wall for
seven hours met his girlfriend on Twitch
and then ran back staring at a wall
again all in the same year this is
[ __ ] [ __ ] you all give him money
while he legitimately just stares at a
[ __ ] wall and you can't help me bio
Tesla
and then that somehow got one up by the
guy who has become the undisputed king
of doing a random [ __ ] online in xqc
when he slept for an entire night on
stream and somehow gained viewership in
the world of live streaming we really
saw the brand of being extremely online
we've all of these different parts of
the Internet together and become
extremely popular in 2019
many of Twitch's biggest stars now have
weekly fixed streams where they just
watch YouTube or react to things stream
or the fact that he no longer has twitch
is back the dude is still killing it as
one of the only
[Music]
[Music]
in fact IRL streaming and hijacking each
other's content got so popular this year
that we saw a bunch of streamers
actually decide to move in together to
make better content from the 100 Thieves
content house to the house we know and
love offline TV to misc if in Arab and
then yeah also the worst streaming house
of all time filled with [ __ ] noise
complaints and eviction notices then I
go in my room there's there's a turd
right there there's a turd right there
there's a turd right there there's turds
everywhere yeah it's pretty [ __ ]
gross but that's just kind of what we've
come to expect in a year where we watch
streamers eat cat food for 250 dollars
[Music]
watch that yeah yeah yeah song for 10
hours and lose their minds watching
something for 10 hours
excuse me literally melting his phone
trying to cook them melted ninja doing
the most cringe floss of all time in the
middle of Times Square
[Music]
get going
[Music]
and who could forget Nick marks
literally proposing to his girlfriend in
front of tens of thousands of people but
as we all now know in the world of
live-streaming it's not just a bit of
twitching maybe the single biggest story
of the year in live streaming started
when ninja announced he was leaving
twitch and going to mixer full con as of
today I will be streaming exclusively on
mixer I know I know it's exciting but
maybe the most dramatic and honestly
hilarious part of all of that was what
happened two ninjas twitch channel after
he left they removed his verified check
mark and then we're advertising for
other streamers on his channel and some
of those ads were not safe for work for
at least a brief period of time there
was porn on ninjas dead twitch channel
and you know he was pissed and they were
still using my channel to promote other
streamers well now there was a port
account that was number one being
recommended on my channel I have no say
in any of this stuff if there's anything
we learned in 2019 if you [ __ ] up so bad
that you make ninja look like the good
guy on Twitter you know you've done
something now with all the drama and
funny moments aside there was obviously
some heartwarming moments that happen on
Twitch this year too it's funny because
sometimes the world of live streaming
can be so dramatic that sometimes we
forget it can bounce back and really
show what an awesome community it is
from this guy who was raising money on
Twitch trying to help his dad beat
cancer so somebody's take us to some of
the people we've literally featured on
this show like Fatih Mellon who donated
hundreds of thousands of dollars just to
help people out on Twitch and how could
you forget maybe the most heartfelt
moment of the entire year when dr. Lupo
raised over 2 million dollars in one
on Twitch for cancer are y'all for real
I mean it's signed by John twitch
himself but yes of course a million
dollars for st. Jude this is a million
dollars from twitch in 2019 we learned
exactly how much generosity and kindness
exists in the same place where people
would watch a guy stare at a wall for
five hours it's the Internet you truly
get the good with the bad and the
heartwarming with the absolutely insane
it was a good year online and we'll see
you next year I'm doing at MIT I'm
thinking of I just watch all three
extended editions actually all right let
me about me in form let me inform don't
at me real quick Buse a core to my room
my roommate did all this math so if you
start the Lord of the Rings trilogy
extended edition at exactly to 13 to 13
and 50 seconds p.m. Eastern Time on New
Year's Eve the Riders of Rohan will
storm the pelennor fields at exactly
midnight so you can have the moment that
everybody always needed right night so
if you guys if you guys are like me and
you're trying to wear gray sweatpants on
New Year's Eve